garantir une sécurité sanitaire pour
rassurer les électeurs mise à
disposition de gel hydroalcoolique
nettoyage régulier du matériel des
règles mises en place dans ce bureau de
vote de guyancourt des préconisations
donné par une circulaire du ministère de
l'intérieur
on évite toutes les manipulations
c'est-à-dire que les personnes qui vont
se présenter pour voter vont nous
présenter leur carte électorale sans que
nous pûmes centre nous la touchons mais
nous pouvons quant à venir le numéro de
la même manière ils vont nous présenter
la carte d'identité ne touchons pas non
plus malgré toutes ces dispositions la
participation est plus faible qu'au
premier tour le 15 mars dernier à
guyancourt trois candidats sont en lice
pour ce second scrutin
le maire sortant françois morton
rodolphe barriques candidats divers
centres et grégory pape tête de la liste
la république en marche il faut
absolument que les gens se mobilisent
on a je trouve pas assez voix au
chapitre on n'est pas assez consultés en
tant que citoyen les rares fois où mon
lait il faut qu'on saisit sa chance en
tant que habitants d'une ville je pense
que c'est important de pouvoir
s'impliquer faire un choix qui
correspondent réellement à ce qu'on a
envie de voir développer dans la vie et
moi en tant que jeune maman ayant des
enfants en âge de scolarité
c'est beaucoup autour de l'éducation que
le choix s'est arrêté et puis aussi sur
le programme d'aménagement de la ville
est ce qu'on peut faire pour mieux vivre
tous ensemble tout simplement mêmes
mesures sanitaires strictes à voisins le
bretonneux où la participation reste
cependant très faible seulement 26
points 47% des électeurs se sont
déplacés à 15 heures ils étaient 34 23 %
à la même heure au premier tour
je suis un peu
qui est de voir qu'il ya si peu de
participation jaspers est uniquement lié
au cogic mais je n'en suis pas sûr pour
moi c'est un droit c'est plus qu'un
droit c'est presque une obligation
voilà je pense que s'occuper de la
municipalité c'est essentiel pour la vie
de la commune et pour nous mêmes les
huit bureaux de vote de la ville sont
ouverts depuis 8h et ferment leurs
portes à 20 heures
tous ont été pensés pour être adapté
consignes sanitaires sens de circulation
port du masque obligatoire et pas plus
de trois électeurs en même temps
malgré tout ça vote quand même un peu
donc on est quand même content de voir
que les gens ont confiance et se
déplacent pour aller jusqu'aux urnes à
voisins le bretonneux trois listes
s'affrontent pour ce second tour celle
de la maire sortante alexandra rosetti
la liste d'union de la droite d'olivier
afonso et une liste divers gauche de
bêtes respira à 17h29
11% des électeurs ont voté dans les
yvelines ils étaient 42 68% à la même
heure en 2014